training doesn't have to be complicated
in fact some of the most practical forms
of training involve doing things we
already do regularly if it's something
you already do then of course it's
something you can benefit from getting
better
at and to flip this on its head this
also shows how anything you do that's
somewhat challenging can also be seen as
a form of training we've all had to walk
with a heavy ruck sack in the past why
not turn it into a workout and we call
this
rocking we shouldn't think of rucking as
only a military activity that's where it
comes from of course being able to carry
a heavy load is very useful if you're in
the Army but trust me I am not cut out
for the military rocking is available to
everyone and could be a rewarding and
enjoyable way to train so what makes it
so great well as a loaded carry rucking
provides a fantastic form of
conditioning you'll be burning more
calories as you you walk because your
muscles need to work harder to move the
extra weight that means you can go for a
shorter Ruck and burn the same calories
in less time as you would on a walk of
the same length or you can Ruck further
and burn even more YouTube is full of
dramatic weight loss stories thanks to
rucking as you progress this also gives
you more options for increasing the
challenge you can increase the distance
you're traveling decrease the time taken
to cover the same distance or just
increase the
weight
this means you won't be going for
increasingly longer and longer walks
there are many ways to
progress and it's ideal for anyone who
finds running to be hard on the knees
because it's much lower impact but it's
much more than just a form of
conditioning rocking also trains almost
the entire body as you walk your body is
forced to stabilize the extra weight
your legs and hips will work harder to
keep you balanced your upper body will
need to brace to support the ruck sack
focus on maintaining your posture and
you'll be improving that too over time
the tendons and ligaments around your
knees will grow stronger and more
resilient you'll feel your glutes carbs
hamstrings and quads working too far
more so than regular walking this won't
give you legs like Mr Olympia but you
might be surprised at the size and
strength that can come from this kind of
training especially if you go
uphill likewise your ankles will need to
stabilize against the extra weight on
the rough terrain this can help to make
you more resistant to Falls and spr
brains by strengthening those small
supporting muscles in general having
stronger and more stable hips and ankles
can reduce injury and improve your
ability to transfer power to the ground
for more explosive athletic performance
the jury is out on how useful unstable
surface training us might be for
increasing ankle Pro reception among the
healthy that means using things like
wobble boards but there is ample
evidence to show the activities like
trail running reduce injuries improve
balance and even increase running speed
that very likely applies here too
possibly more so given the added weight
and you're not just building strength in
these areas but strength endurance in
all the places you need it for practical
movement real world tasks that don't
involve simply lifting something heavy
once and putting it back down you'll
become a Workhorse and activities that
once seemed challenging will be far more
manageable and you'll be grounded
planted firmly in the ground and better
able to generate power from the bottom
up the strength goes deep the added load
bearing could even help to strengthen
your very bones weight bearing over
longer durations is well known for doing
this oh and of course you get all the
health benefits associated with simply
being outdoors including those ever so
important mental health benefits this is
a moving
meditation so how do you get started
well it's actually very easy all you
need is a ruck sack and some weight to
go in it you don't need a lot of weight
and you don't need a fancy ruck sack you
can buy weights specifically made for
rucking but a few water bottles will do
just as well and you can drink the water
if you start getting tired start light
and only add more as you get confident
with the
process try to distribute the weight in
the Rock sack evenly keeping the
heaviest items closest to your
back then you might consider in in a
slightly better ruck sack look for one
with a hip belt and chest strap this
will help you to support the load closer
to your body and stop it from bouncing
around rubbing not to mention better
Distributing the load across your torso
wider straps will also help reduce
rubbing and of course you need a bag
that's tough enough to hold the
weight as for footware look for
something that will offer a little ankle
support especially to begin with that
said I person personally like shoes that
let me use my feet as naturally as
possible that's where today's sponsor
Vivo Barefoot comes in Vivo Barefoot
make minimal shoes with a wide toe box
giving you plenty of surface area and
allowing your feet to move with the
Contour of the
ground they also include minimal heals
meaning you aren't walking with your
carves in a constantly shortened
position you'll have better sensitivity
and be better able to feel the ground
beneath you this not only makes for a
far more stimulating experience not only
strengthens the muscles of the feet and
lower legs not only makes you more
grounded as you walk but also helps to
reduce your chances of a twisted ankle
the best thing about all of this is that
Vivo Barefoot make a variety of shoes
that take all these boxes at once like
their tracker range The Trackers are
lightweight hiking boots with
multi-terrain grip and extra Flex they
give you all the freedom and flexibility
of barefoot shoes but offer the extra
support you need when doing something
like rucking it's great to have a shoe
that I can recommend without reservation
for this kind of activity of course
they're also perfect for hiking
adventuring and generally getting down
and
dirty bioner viewers can get 15% off
their order by using Code the bioner 15
check them out in the link
below speaking of terrain of course the
next question is where to Ruck and the
answer is once again anywhere heck you
can rock around town heading out anyway
why not throw some added weight into
that ruck sack and turn it into
incidental training but for many
exploring somewhere beautiful is part of
the appeal and in that case you might
consider driving to a local Beauty Spot
if you have one and exploring varied
terrain like Hills mud sand and water
can all add to the challenge and the
stability
gains while also giving you a more
interesting and varied workout of course
you do need to work up to those more
challenging routes consider ice and mud
and spend some time on flatter ground
until you've built that base make sure
you have a way to navigate and to call
for help if you need it and don't head
out too far without considering how
you're going to get back if you're
concerned about burning out there's no
shame in doing laps of a smaller area
but truly there are no rules this is
just walking but harder do it how you
want just know that it's an exciting
opportunity for those that want to
improve their strength stability
endurance and body composition you just
need a ruck sack and some
weight now Rock Off
for